the realm
do you know what the realm is
it's the thousand blades of aegon's
enemies
a story we agreed to tell each other
over
and over till we forget that it's a lie
what's up ladies and gentlemen welcome
back for another house of the dragon
update video
as you all know hbo is working on
another show that's set within the song
of ice and fire universe
created by the amazing author george rr
martin
this is something they started working
on before game of thrones even ended
in this new series we will learn more
about the history of house targaryen
it's based on george rr martin's fire
and blood starting roughly
300 years before the events of game of
thrones
now what's great is george is also
listed as one of the co-creators for
house of the dragon but it will mostly
be written by ryan condell
who is also one of the showrunners
alongside miguel sapochnick
when i first found out miguel sapochnick
would be one of the showrunners for
house of the dragon
i got very excited because he is
responsible for directing some of the
greatest episodes in television history
for those of you that might not know
miguel sapochnick is well known for
directing episodes like heart home
battle of the bastards and the winds of
winter this man knows how to make a
one-hour episode feel like a cinematic
experience
and in fact i would say he knows how to
make a one-hour episode look even better
than a lot of the blockbuster movies we
see today
but maybe that's just me so not only is
george rr martin co-creating this show
but miguel sapochnick is also directing
every single episode
in this first season that's a very good
sign that hbo is setting up their new
series for success
now i just hope the writing is on the
same level as the directing
now shortly after game of thrones ended
hbo announced that house of the dragon
would be released in 2022
unfortunately ever since kovitz spread
across the entire globe
studios have shut down their production
on a lot of films and television shows
since there were so many different
industries affected by this
i would have almost guaranteed house of
the dragon would get delayed
well as of right now that is not the
case
casey bloys who is the president of hbo
was recently interviewed by deadline
and during the interview casey confirmed
that casting for the series is currently
underway
and that the drama is still on track for
a 2022 launch
this is very exciting because it looks
like we won't have to wait much longer
to be able to dive
back into the lives of all these amazing
characters created by george rr martin
so it looks like fire will rain soon
enough
there have been a lot of rumors lately
about hbo looking for actors to fill the
roles of some of the main characters for
the series
now that it's actually been confirmed i
expect to see
some major updates very soon depending
on which actors they get
we may be able to figure out what time
period the first season will cover
one thing they have yet to confirm is if
the first season will start with
aegon's conquest or if it will begin by
setting up the dance of the dragons
honestly i think either option will be
fantastic
now one thing is for sure and that is we
will absolutely see
more dragons so if any of you were
worried that this show was cancelled
or gonna get delayed you no longer have
to worry because it is now confirmed to
still be on schedule for its original
release date
now that we know casting is underway it
will not be long before they start
filming
and if any of you have been following my
channel from the beginning
then you already know exactly what that
means
as soon as they start filming legitimate
spoilers and leaks will start to come
out and you know i'll be here making
videos on them every
step of the way just like i did for game
of thrones
as i have always said before whenever i
find out something
all of you will be the first ones to
know during the off seasons for game of
thrones i was relentlessly making videos
on every single
update or spoiler i could find i will do
the same thing for house of the dragon
as soon as filming starts in a few
months you can expect to see a lot more
videos from me because i like to discuss
what they're up to during the entire
process so
get ready folks because house of the
dragon is on the way
now i definitely need to start making
those videos on every chapter in fire
and blood
so we can all get a good idea of what we
can expect to see in the successor show
i said i would make those videos as well
as my song of ice and fire chapter
videos so that's what i will start to do
if any of you would like to get early
access to my videos i would really
appreciate it if you could sign up for
my patreon
that link is down below in the
description either way
i hope to see all of you back here for
the next video thanks for watching
i will see you again very soon bye
[Music]
[Music]
you